Y de nuevo surgió aquella pregunta: ¿por qué no habríamos de hacerlo?
En la imagen se ve parte de 426 alumnos de la primaria
que subieron la colina con el director de la escuela
que no quiso privar a los alumnos de esta gran oportunidad.
Y, tal como ocurre en el desierto de Nevada,
aunque con temperaturas levemente distintas,
(Risas)
la gente de esta comunidad, 65 000 personas,
empezaron a escribir sus penas, sus dolores, sus esperanzas,
sus esperanzas para el futuro, su amor.
Porque, al fin y al cabo, de eso se trata: del amor.
Viven en una sociedad de posconflicto,
con muchos casos de estrés postraumático, altas tasas de suicidio.
Pero aun así, por un instante,
y no podríamos pretender que haya sido más que eso,
un hombre llamado Kevin, católico, que perdió a su padre a los nueve años,
cuando fue baleado en su cama,
trabajó para nosotros como voluntario.
Y fue el primero en recibir a la anciana protestante
que atravesó la puerta el día en que abrimos el templo al público.
El templo permaneció allí durante cinco días.
Luego, entre los miembros del reducido equipo de obreros no sectáreos
que habían dado su vida durante esos meses
para finalmente lograr esta obra extraordinaria,
elegimos a quienes prenderían fuego al templo.
Y aquí vemos el momento presenciado por 15 000 personas
que acudieron una fría y oscura noche de marzo,
cuando decidieron dejar de lado la enemistad que los separaba
para habitar este espacio compartido,
donde todos tuvieron la oportunidad de decir abiertamente
lo que antes nunca se habían dicho:
"Me has herido a mí y a mi familia, pero te perdono".
Y juntos, como miembros de su comunidad,
fueron testigos de esto tan bello que se iba diluyendo,
pero que era tan difícil de dejar ir,
al igual que los sentimientos y las ideas que lo habían creado.
(Música)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)